(intriguing music)
- [Presenter] Tensions
over Taiwan have soared.
A visit from House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
and comments from other US officials
about the island have infuriated China.
(speaking in foreign language)
The self-ruled island has
grown into a durable democracy
and major semiconductor producer.
The US has promised to
help it defend itself.
- [Reporter] Are you willing
to get involved militarily
to defend Taiwan if it comes to that?
- Yes.
- [Presenter] But the problem is,
China sees it as part of its own territory
and has threatened to
seize it if necessary.
- Over the past year, the Chinese military
has also sent dozens of planes,
bombers and fighter jets
into the air space close to Taiwan.
- [Presenter] So as Taiwan is perhaps
the most explosive issue
in US-China relations,
here's how we got here and what's next.
The first thing to know is that Taiwan,
which is located off China's coast,
has been self-governed since 1949.
That's when the Communist Party
took power in mainland China
and some nationalists fled to the island.
- For China, Taiwan is seen
as always been the one that got away.
When the Chinese Communist Party
first founded the People's
Republic of China,
Taiwan was never a part
of the People's Republic.
Instead it was governed
by the Kuomintang Party
that had fled to the island
after brutal civil war.
Ever since then, every
Chinese leader has sought
to reunify Taiwan with the mainland.
- [Presenter] And that
includes President Xi Jinping
who has made bringing Taiwan
under mainland control
a key goal of his legacy.
(speaking in foreign language)
But the US has shown support
for President Tsai Ing-wen.
From Beijing's perspective, she's a leader
who is dangerously pushing
Taiwan closer to independence.
(grandiose music)
(camera shutter clicking)
Taiwan became a bigger
bilateral issue between the US
and China during the
administration of President Trump.
- What president Donald
Trump did was to make it
part of US policy to
tighten ties with Taiwan
and this has continued
under President Biden.
- [Presenter] For decades,
the US has sent weapons
and more recently, has sent troops
to provide military training
despite China's warnings.
The US has a few reasons to do that.
- Firstly, it's the US'
ninth largest trading partner
and Taiwan is also a key
part of global supply chains.
Taiwan is also a litmus
test for US credibility
in the region, because the US allies
will watch US' treatment
of Taiwan carefully.
- [Presenter] One reason Taiwan
is so strategic for the US and China
is the role it plays in manufacturing.
It's home to the world's
most critical chip-maker
and semiconductors have
been in short supply
over the past year.
So what's next?
China has made a series
of moves in the region
in what Taiwan sees as attempts
to discourage the island
from forging closer ties
with the US and other allies.
- What we've seen is a PLA unit posting
on a social media account the video
of a recent military drill that happened
off the coast of
southeastern Fujian province
and facing Taiwan.
The caption of the video read,
"We're ready to fight any time."
- [Presenter] China
also said it would hold
live fire military drills
around Taiwan in early August,
but this doesn't mean China
will actually invade the island,
which carries a lot of risk
considering Washington's pledges
to help Taiwan defend itself.
(intriguing music)
Taiwan is one of a number of issues
such as trade and
technology that have soured
US-China relations in recent years.
Despite the risks of escalation,
the US is signaling that
even with war raging
in Ukraine, it can remain very active
in the strategic Asia-Pacific region.
- If the US doesn't stand up
for Taiwan in the face of China coercion,
then US credibility in the region suffers
and it would affect its relationship
with other allies in the region.